Así es Rodrigo Bueno pues vamos a decir
que uno cero con la victoria de Beatriz
Maya esta mañana en un maratón de
prácticamente cuatro horas antes Sara
sorribes a tomo la jugadora española muy
aguerrida ella que de hecho logró
remontar el primer set cuando ya la
brasileña iba cinco dos adelante
finalmente pues Maya quien reaccionó y
logró quedarse con este partido Pero
bueno dejó sangre sudor y lágrimas en
esa cancha y bueno se convierta en la
primera brasileña en más de 50 años en
estar en los cuartos de final de una
gran slam ella ahora va a medirse en la
próxima ronda ante la tunecina la número
siete del mundo que hoy se deshizo
facilito en tan solo dos sets y un
poquito menos de una hora de bernarda
pera de Estados Unidos y ante pues
Francisco cerúndolo perdió su partido
ante holger uno del danés quien
finalmente pues dio una muy buena
batalla ser un duro también en realidad
seguramente va a estar digamos
jugando todos los puntos perdidos a lo
largo de este partido que terminó
resolviéndose en un súper
y pues ojo junio que jugó ahí un poco
digamos se supo manejar mejor tal vez
los nervios sobre el final de este
partido y que ahora pues ha avanzado a
la siguiente ronda aquí en París pues
era difícil ese partido de la brasileña
frente a ver estaremos muy atentos a lo
que siga por otro lado Natalia este
lunes también se ha jugado el partido de
uno de los favoritos en el cuadro
masculino es el noruego casperrut frente
también a otro latinoamericano el
chileno Nicolás Harry allí no hubo
sorpresa Natalia Qué pasó en este
partido
no no hubo sorpresa pero bueno se
esperaba que fuera un muy buen partido y
lo fue de hecho Jerry puso contra las
cuerdas a Casper Ruth y prueba de esto
es el resultado de este partido siete
seis siete cinco siete cinco Esos son
los parciales con los que ganó casperú
del número cuatro del mundo este
encuentro en un poco más de tres horas y
20 minutos partido también bastante
difícil estuvo muy bien ya de hecho
había vencido a casperrut hace tan solo
10 días en el torneo de Ginebra y bueno
Casper Ruth consiguió En todo caso su
venganza y ahora se cita una vez más por
segundo año consecutivo en cuartos de
final ante uno y estamos esperando los
resultados bueno que empiece de hecho el
partido del último latinoamericano en
Lisa el día de hoy se trata de Tomás
Echeverría el argentino que va a medirse
ante el japonés que antes no sean
enfrentado pero que se conocen bien
porque se entrenaron juntos el año
pasado en el Abierto de Estados Unidos y
mientras tanto antes de que empiece ese
partido está la número uno de la mundo y
jugando ante la ucraniana